No,
if you look at plastic hero mythology,
which we're going to do in great detail,
what you see is that the typical myth of
it,
of humanity is we live in a place,
will say we have to live in a place and
the place is doing quite nicely.
Thank you very much.
It's like the hobbits and,
and,
uh,
Frodo,
right?
The first one,
the Lord that the,
uh,
what was it called?
The hobbit.
Okay,
so you've got a little shy or they're
right.
It's all peaceful.
It's full of these little people who are
a little on the arrogant side.
They're kind of dopey.
They have no idea what the hell is going
on in the outside world,
but they think that's okay.
They think,
you know,
just,
peculiar people are concerned about that
sort of thing.
They got their little happy paradise
going.
They live a long time,
they eat a lot,
you know,
they party a lot unbeknownst to them,
which is very interesting feature of the
story.
The only reason they have any peace at
all,
it's because they are descendants of old
kings continually patrolling the
borders.
Right?
Those are the striders Aragorn.
He's the member of the race of old kings
who patrols the borders.
Well,
those are.
Those are ancestral figures.
It's like you can all sit here,
your little happy paradise,
but the only reason you can do it is
because the sons of great kings have put
borders around your kingdom and you can
think it's funny because in the hobbits,
hobbits basically despise strider.
You're like,
you're very,
very suspicious of him.
He's kind of dirty and dusty and they
looks like he's been banged around all
over the world.
He started like a trap.
It's like they don't know.
He's the son of a great king.
Good thing for them that he is,
however.
Okay,
so then you've got the little shyer and
what happens even though things are
stirring and what is it?
Well,
fundamentally it's a great dragon.
that's a snake,
except it's like medicine snake,
you know,
it's,
it's snake with fire and you can be sure
that fire was not only one of our
greatest allies,
but one of our greatest enemies,
especially when we lived on the Veltin
Africa,
because that thing would burn now in
them,
you know,
and so get the hell away from that as
well.
So anyways,
so one hobbit,
who's woken up by a wizard,
the wizard is a symbol of the cell from
the union perspective.
So there's one hobbit who's a little bit
more creative and exploratory than the
rest,
and everybody has a level of respect for
him,
but they think he's pretty damn
peculiar.
He decides that he's gonna under the
tutelage of the wizard.
He's going to go check out this dragon.
So he leaves the borders and he goes out
into the unknown.
And then the rest of it is an adventure.
And one of the things that's very
interesting again,
from a union perspective is that what is
the hobbit have to become in order to
conquer the Dragon?
A thief?
Now that's pretty weird,
a because you think,
hey man,
this guy's out to be a hero,
so he should be a hero.
It's like,
no,
he turns into a thief.
Why?
Well,
it's because if you're going to conquer
a dragon,
you be a hell of a lot tougher than you
are naive,
and so partly what happens is that for
the hobbit to muster up the forces that
are necessary for him to confront
something that that is that fundamental,
he asked to transcend his towered.
What would you call it?
The the cowardice that he describes as
morality.
Okay,
so need shift,
for example,
niche is often viewed as a critic critic
of morality.
It's like that's not true.
What?
Because nature identifies morality with
cowardice,
but that's not what he does.
What Nisha says is this,
if you're too afraid to do something so
you won't do it,
then you'll say that the reason that you
don't do it is because your moral.
That's not the reason.
The reason is it's you're too damn
afraid to do it.
You might want to,
but you're too afraid.
That doesn't make you moral.
So what happens to the Harvard,
for example,
is once he gets outside the kingdom,
he asked to develop a whole array of
potentials that he never developed
before because they were either not
necessary in his civilized place or
because they were forbidden as immoral
by the cultural situation that he grew
up there.